[Music]
and we didn't even circle this game
this is just another game
we ain't worried about it i'm going to
tell you again man they were who we
thought they were y'all can crown them
if you want to crown them still got to
play football
titan sight and delaney walker after the
30-point victory over the cleveland
browns paying homage to the late great
dennis green coined that phrase after a
loss to the bears when he was coaching
the car were they up like 21-000
it was unreal i remember that night
because that was one of those where you
just you're so it happens after the game
let's see the press conference he hits
the microphone drops a couple of bs
bombs and uh it was just awesome but uh
not for the cardinals that night awesome
for the titans yesterday all right the
draft today the biggest statements
coming out of the first sunday the
regular season and i i'm posing the
question to you to determine who gets
the first pick patrick mahomes has now
thrown for more yards in his first 20
games than anyone in nfl history whose
record did he break
gosh i got to think that's
first 20 games i got to think that's dan
marino oh no it's your good friend kurt
warner bert warner held the record wow
that's impressive now held by patrick
mahomes mahomes also has the record for
the most touchdown passes in his first
20 games with 53 and he's only played in
18 regular season games he's got two
more games to go yeah to really set the
bar at a spot where it may never be
matched all right i get the first pick
and i mean this is one of those days
where it's good to have the first pick
because without question the biggest
statement was made by the tennessee
titans who went to cleveland and didn't
just eke out a victory see i really
don't enjoy my prediction as much as i
thought i was going to because i didn't
expect it to be a bloodbath
if i'd have picked a blood that you'd
have thought i was
permanently residing in crazyville if i
had picked a 30-point victory by the
titans but yeah i i saw this coming i
saw the wind coming but not the way that
it happened and we have to start taking
the titan seriously now kevin baier told
me after the game that this wasn't just
like delaney walker said we didn't
circle this game yeah we're trying to go
from good team to great team and the
moment we get on the plane we are done
thinking about this game and we are on
to the colts i mean
most teams take a day they're on to the
colts the minute their butts hit the
seats on the plane and that tells me
this team is serious about proving all
of us wrong because when we put together
our afc south hierarchy who consistently
ended up at the bottom
he's a titan yes you're right they were
they were the bottom it one of those
like a good bottom but it was the bottom
look at it now though yes the jaguars
don't have a quarterback the colts don't
have their franchise quarterback right
the texans it feels like the fish is
rotting from the head down in houston
and uh and maybe the titans are going to
be
maybe maybe they're the ones who are
going to win the division yeah i mean
listen i would not be shocked i would
like to say that we talked about you
know yeah i picked the titans to come in
last but like but it could have been any
of them just like the nfc north any of
them can win it and any of them can
finish
exactly right that's how i felt all
along i was always prefacing that with
going if the tennessee titans got in the
playoffs i'm not going to be sitting
here and go oh my gosh i can't believe
that happened i mean they certainly have
enough players and good coaching to make
that happen good start for them not a
bad pick by you but i'm going to go with
the dallas cowboys is my sunday biggest
statement on sunday because
first off dallas is such a up and down
type of football team and last year they
went to the playoffs and history shows
us that this is the year they fall off
earth and don't go to the playoffs well
not only did they not do that uh they
had to deal with distractions here in
preseason because of zeke zeke elliott
thing you know dak prescott are they
gonna sign him to a long-term deal oh
they have a new offensive coordinator
what's going to happen there well hey
the giants came into town who have
traditionally played the dallas cowboys
very tough uh eli manning not
intimidated by what goes on down there
and zeke elliott in the running game
weren't the story of the game this is
why it was such a big statement dallas
is saying watch out we're legit this
year we're not like only going to be
able to win games if ezekiel elliott
runs for a hundred yards we can win a
number of different ways and i think
that is awesome i'm pumped for it we
knew their defense was good we knew
their offensive line and running game
were good we wanted to see if the pass
game could open things up and truly make
them like
an unstoppable looking offense and they
at least started that way yesterday and
and give me confidence that they're
going to be a force to be reckoned with
with the pass game and run game both and
dak prescott completely unflustered by
the pending contract negotiations it
would be very easy to to make it a
distraction we've had this conversation
many times
the the concern a player has that he's
going to get himself injured right as
he's on the cusp of grabbing that giant
brass ring well that's where prescott
apparently has jerry jones the owner of
the cowboy said after the game the deal
is imminent but then with a who knows
whoever knows what jerry jones means and
how much of it is for effect and how
much of it is for negotiation
if dak prescott will take what they want
him to take right right and the question
is does he want more now after having
405 passing yards zeke did a team
friendly deal
you know jalen smith did a team friendly
deal 50 million over four years is not
team friendly that's pretty damn team
friendly that's that's not that bad four
years 50 million for the best running
back in football i've seen worse two and
12 and a half million a year you wanted
to get that and here's the thing it all
comes down to whether you want to get to
a certain number on an average and new
money i mean zeke signed for eight years
total so that'd be a little
there's gonna be devil in the details
you just had to fight against me you
couldn't i don't want to fight against
you all the time i i don't think we've
mentioned this game at all over the last
hour and a half and they're going to be
vikings fans out there who are kind of
pissed off that we haven't mentioned the
game i was about to go there but the
vikings stuck it to the falcons right
they stuck it baby i mean it was 28
nothing it looks better than it was when
it finishes 28 12. but the vikings were
all over them and the best statement i
think comes from the offense where
dalvin cook had 21 carries 111 yards
yeah and here's the thing right the
vikings have finally figured out how to
properly use kirk cousins yeah as little
as possible right 8 for 10. this isn't
the first quarter stat line 8 for 10 for
98 yards he threw for 98 yards and
dalvin cook ran for a hundred and eleven
look you don't need to do it when your
defense and your special teams are
setting you up with fields they had the
block punt early they had an
interception early it was 14 nothing
before you know it the the uh that
falcons were driving in the second
quarter and there was a fumble in
vikings territory and the vikings took
it the other way and made it 21-nothing
so um look hey
you you win however you have to win and
every game is going to be different and
the vikings
capitalized on their opportunities the
mistakes that were made by the falcons
and the falcons just didn't look good
and maybe it's the vikings made them not
look good there's some concerning things
about the the falcons all pre-season i
mean there is for one i mean their
offensive line is an issue it is and
they couldn't run the ball or pass
protect all that well yesterday matt
ryan made some bonehead mistakes i'm
glad you brought up the vikings i was
going to talk about them too i was going
to specifically talk about dalvin cook
because he made a statement to say like
watch out i'm gonna be in the
conversation for one of the best running
backs in football this year i mean he
was i mean he was flying around the
field yesterday and you know you just
couldn't help but just to bag on your
quarterback a little bit you just he was
eight for 10. he didn't have to i mean
when you're defensive why are you giving
him 28 million dollars a year when
you're gonna have to throw ten okay well
that's just the way it fell yesterday it
was a two play 21-yard drive or a
touchdown a four-play 41-yard drive for
a touchdown you know they did have a
10-play 79-yard drive and a six-play
80-yard drive where he made some some
big throws but that's all the game
dictated he didn't need to do anything
crazy stop taking shots at your damn
quarterback he's your quarterback you
should stick up for him okay that was my
tarello it wasn't very good i know you
you can't be smiling when you do it you
gotta get sunglasses on yeah all right
uh okay
yeah um
did this just
oh yeah you know who made a statement on
sunday the new england patriots they
said oh yeah we're gonna be awesome
again and uh we haven't even unleashed
antonio brown yet hey our passing game's
great doesn't matter it's like that was
like a statement to the nfl and it was
like a statement to antonio brown who
was like sitting at home watching the
game going damn they don't really need
me that much i better act accordingly
here or they will kick my butt out of
the door in three seconds what do you
think gronk
thinks when he sees what happened this
is what's amazing about new england and
this is where people get mad at me
because they think i don't like new
england and i love new england and this
is why they get mad at me because
everybody gives brady the credit whoa
brady threw a three yard pass to josh
gordon and then he broke six tackles and
ran for a touchdown that's not taking
anything away from brady it's just
everything about them is amazing okay i
mean you're seeing this i mean receivers
are open all over the field and brady's
still awesome i'm not trying to take
anything away from them but this they're
a machine like we've never seen before
in the history of the nfl no gronk
whatever it doesn't matter they can just
make it happen because they got some
really really awesome players a great
quarterback and an unreal coaching staff
it also helped that the patriots defense
ended up being yeah very very good yes
without it and i don't know how much i
wanted to get into that but i was just
talking i don't know how much of it is
the steelers just weren't clicking
offensively because no matter how much
you say hey we're going to be all banded
together
you don't have antonio brown you don't
have le'veon because they have no
mismatch for that that patriots
secondary that's going to be the biggest
issue then and that all falls down to
juju smith schuster just don't say okay
this guy was great as the number two
let's make him the number one and
everything will be fine yeah it's like
if michael irvin had left the cowboys
and you take alvin harper and you make
him the number one right we saw how that
movie went when alvin harper left to be
the number one elsewhere it didn't go
well pick your third pick i'm making my
third pick my third pick is the
baltimore ravens 59 to 10 old school ass
whipping that
that was like there were games like that
in the 70s yes when the talent gap
between the best team and the worst team
in the nfl was gigantic and every once
in a while the best team in the worst
team would end up playing on the same
field at the same time in this day and
age is not supposed to be that dramatic
now is this gonna happen i i feel like
this is either gonna happen at the
dolphins a lot this year or the ravens
are gonna do this a lot to a bunch of
different people i don't think this is
an aberration for both teams we'll find
out but it's the dolphins welcoming the
patriots town next weekend and you
always say that miami's a tough place to
play i don't think it's going to be all
that hard no
for the patriots who've had a hard time
there yeah in recent years i doubt that
next sunday no negative ghost rider the
patriots are 2-0 let's lock it in okay
it's over it's not even let's not even
make him play the game but yeah it was
phenomenal we knew the defense was
amazing we knew the run game was amazing
and lamar was awesome they're favored by
16 next week yeah i'm not shocked okay
i'm gonna i'm really torn here because i
kind of want to pick josh allen but i'm
not going to because he did make a
statement in the second half of that
game i'm going to go with the los
angeles rams is my statement game oh
super bowl hangover
oh todd gurley oh we got to go to the
east coast and play a one o'clock game
10 10 10 a.m pacific oh it doesn't
really matter we're the rams we find a
freaking way to win no matter what
except in the super bowl well okay but
damn it's just more times than not they
find the ways to win the games they do
yes the super bowl was ugly but uh
yesterday i think you know i know i
picked the panthers you picked the
panthers i believe too right yeah it's
upset yes and uh the rams just kind of
they find ways and girly shut you up
yesterday how do i remember who you
picked but you don't remember who i
picked you're not that important why
would i remember what you say i don't
know
all right quick recap of the statements
made i'm ready for you this time uh
statements made on sunday the titans
vikings and ravens for me the cowboys
patriots and rams winning christopher i
don't know
we're gonna wrap up this monday edition
of pfc live getting ready for the
doubleheader monday night football when
pfd live continues right after this
tiger's blood in my veins
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports